we're on the right path where we're
getting there i'm optimistic that it's
people like you that didn't
allow people like me to be on stage and
be heard will make a difference also to
so many people who are actually
listening to it and saying hey this
makes sense
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders this is
going to be a really fun episode with
hilah ovil brenna managing director of
the techstars tel aviv accelerator
having led her first company white smoke
to a successful ipo the past 20 years
zila has grown into a serial
entrepreneur investor and mentor in the
high-tech industry specializing in
early-stage startup development and
growth she has been named the top 100
influential people in the israeli
high-tech ecosystem by israeli
technology site geek time additionally
he lies the founder of yazamiyot the
largest female founders group in israel
with over 4 000 founders located
throughout the country and dozens of
global projects in the works
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you're
literally one of the most influential
figures in our ecosystem tackling and
some of the most important topics and in
the tech ecosystem in general as a
serial entrepreneur yourself as a
startup mentor as um the the co-founder
of some of the the most amazing
initiatives that are promoting women in
tech um but but literally making moving
the needle and making an impact and so
i'm looking forward to
sort of putting together
this
the this perspective of yours and this
journey of yours and then touch on these
different experiences and how they fit
this puzzle of who is the gila and and i
want to start exactly there and if if
you sort of take a greater look at at
who you are and and what you truly care
about sort of your motivations when you
wake up in the morning
how do you think through
yourself you know who who is the gila
wow so it's a big question first of all
i'm just really excited to be here and
speak to your audience i think you are
doing an amazing job
um and i think it's really really
important so when i look at what gets me
up in the morning and i guess we spoke
about those
um it's it's about promoting
entrepreneurs so i myself was a founder
my whole life i know how difficult it is
to be a founder i have a lot of gray
hairs from the roller coasters of being
nearly through everything fundraising
mergers acquisitions ipos a lot of
things
most of them were failures some of them
were success
and so what really gets me up in the
morning is to help entrepreneurs make
less mistakes and maybe make their life
a little bit easier
uh yet maintaining the energy and the
fun of being an entrepreneur
and also when you mentioned it promoting
female founders you know when i was a
young founder i was always alone in the
room and i felt like maybe there was
something wrong with that a little bit
and i didn't see enough investors i
didn't see enough moms
so my dream was to actually create
i would say initiatives that would help
women feel a little bit more at home
and would bring more role models to the
game and kind of what i'm doing at the
moment
incredible take me back to
to your own startup journey for a second
just so that
i can i can really grasp the this
mentality of yours because it seems that
a lot of the things that you're doing
today whether it's with tech stars or
with a theater
or campus they'll be for moms
which i have to talk about soon
it it a lot of it stemmed from your
personal experience both the the
hardships but also the the success
and so
what sort of how did you leave that
entrepreneurial journey what were those
what were those different feelings and
intentions like yeah well i'm glad to be
speaking about that because uh in my
history i was actually a lawyer so uh
i didn't think i didn't have the dream
to be an entrepreneur since i was a
young child or something i wish i could
say that but i didn't
i was just really really bored and i was
looking for more energetic creative
things so i was reading through papers
and saw how many people
were involved with the innovation
ecosystem and it was incredible to me
and i wanted to get more energy into my
life and so i started my first company
with the
um it was a grammar checker um it was
called white smoke and it was a big
passion of mine to write better english
and
um
and to cut a long story short it was
back in the days when natural language
processing was
a really rough world out there and there
weren't a lot of
you know it was really sophisticated and
i remember we really went on this
journey
with the idea that we will create a
product that people would use and yes
ultimately the end game is that millions
of people around the world actually use
it we signed great
contracts with a lot of great
enterprises
so the end game was really good and the
energy of starting a startup and getting
a team together and sitting in a small
room and eating pizza and and dreaming
how you're going to conquer the world
that really got me up uh and that you
know it's what really made me uh want to
go on this journey the only thing is
when you're young and very gullible and
very naive and you don't know how
everything works
it's really difficult so today a lot of
founders are more fortunate to have
mentors to have programs to have
actually vcs
that are
thought provoking that are leaders
and that can really help them
create partnerships etc so that's kind
of what got me into into
entrepreneurship
and that
that that intrinsic motivation to then
go and make and move the needle in your
own community and create a zamiyot and
create campus television for moms and
the other organizations
sort of where did that come from because
there is a sacrifice there
and and it's not trivial to go and
create these programs and so what what
was sort of going through your arm yeah
well it's a big sacrifice because you're
you have your day job and then you have
this organization which started actually
in my back garden with five
women uh founders and i never thought it
was gonna get that big i just wanted to
get some ceos to speak together and
actually help each other connect
and become role models for each other so
that they don't feel like
it's out of the game because i was
feeling like everywhere i went whether
it was the teacher at school or the
neighbor or my actual immediate family
um everyone was like are you crazy you
know this would be a big sacrifice and
possibly you would not be able to be a
good mom and you know there was a whole
big thing so my initiative around female
founders was to actually help um
founders actually feel more comfortable
in their own skin like not be exactly
like men but be a bit different and so i
raised a lot of money both when i was
pregnant and had i have three amazing
kids and
i'm lucky because i have a lot of
support uh for that but i wanted to get
people together and i wanted women to
feel more comfortable
so if you and and how many how many
women ended up being a part of the azam
youth program so far so yes
is the largest organization it's the
leading organization for tech female
founders in israel there's over 8 000
female founders
we have incredible programs you
mentioned one compass for mars which i'd
love to talk about but also
an incredible one with aws
microsoft for startups has run a few
very very important initiatives and so
the idea of usmyot which started off as
a small group in my garden was actually
to grow and become
a more substantial in actually giving uh
tools to women founders and this is
actually what i do at textures as well
because
i at textures as well help diversity and
inclusion on a global level and on an
israeli level as well
and i try to see as much diversity in my
portfolio so
amazing i mean a lot a lot of people
talk about diversity in tech today and
probably most people that talk about or
don't actually do much about it but they
like talking about it
but but i'm
curious you know with 8 000 members and
starting in your own backyard and
having you gone through
personally this process even before you
had this the support of community
what did you learn what i mean what is
what does it come down to
that that you think today if i were to
ask you gila
you're in a position of of change
what what really does need to happen in
the field
to try and move the needle
not in 50 years but in five years
what do we need to do that's a really
amazing question thanks for asking that
i i want to say that um actually um i i
am optimistic okay let's start with the
end i i do feel that the needle is
starting to move it's moving slowly but
it is moving
i'm seeing a lot of very good people
trying to move the needle whether
they're vcs um
whether they're um programs
entrepreneurship programs
uh and entrepreneurs themselves i mean
the more female founders
but the numbers are still very low and
the question is
why is it and everyone has different you
know answers to this but if you ask me
about my answer i mean i could be wrong
but this is how i feel i think it needs
to come both from the top
right and it also needs to come from the
bottom so as women we need to support
each other too
and it needs to come from the top where
like um the mentality needs to change a
bit in different places which it is
changing
and so both top and bottom need to um
move closer and i feel that they are so
it's good
and if you talk to me religious about
campus tlv for moms i remember this
program as a kid i remember how much
motivation it gave me
i obviously have a personal connection
to this program but tell me about this
idea that you had and it's a very it's
not it's not a traditional
uh
mentorship program if you will
it's not every day that something like
this happens it's once in a lifetime uh
there's an incredible video about it i
can post later
on you um a small video of how how it
was done the idea was to actually
help women
that are on maternity leave and instead
of just walking around and finding any
woman just because she's a mom and she's
a mom they have to be friends this is a
great time in a woman's life to make a
change because a lot of them don't
really want to go back to their own
way of living in their own previous
careers
and so the idea was to actually create a
baby friendly school
men and women so whoever is on maternity
leave could come with their baby
we put beautiful mattresses on the floor
and we're very very fortunate that
google
the israeli
branch in google really took this
took us to heart and really adopted this
idea and and like just went with the
flow it was just too incredible for
words we had seven cycles here in israel
and wow it also became international and
until today i meet women who still say
this touched my life in such different
ways because not only were great
startups created
also if it wasn't created only three
four years down the line they still
became really really good friends and
many startups started afterwards
and so the idea is that a big company
like google could just take
an idea like this
and support it in such an incredible way
and you'll see matthias
professor yosem matthias was a a a
supporter for those like an incredible
supporter for those as well as my uh
partner tal sarik who was there in the
marketing department
and um it just felt like everything we
did was like really move the needle
because everyone came over the energy
was there start was recreated we had a
few exits and very successful companies
from there
and it felt like this was a really good
time
to create a program like this
beautiful obviously and not a plug for
for professor yosemite who i love very
much but um i think it's just it's it is
non-traditional i mean i remember as a
kid walking in and seeing
you know and walking into campus tel
aviv because that's where i used to
sometimes come in and work on some
hackathon stuff and all of a sudden i
see i see you know in this huge room i
see women with their with their babies
and and and i i love what you mentioned
that
pregnancy or maternity leave is actually
a an amazing time for change i think
that until now mostly when i've been
hearing people talk about maternity
leave it's been with sort of a
dismissive feeling that this is when the
career is stopping this is when
promotions are halting
career trajectories get stopped and
you're actually saying no no no this is
a time for for maybe change for
reflection for self-improvement
and actually a stepping stone for a new
career which which i think is very
different than than perhaps even still
today most women think about maternity
leave right
exactly i think this is a really great
time in a woman's life to make a change
uh and lay the foundation for really the
rest of her life and something really
important is i think
uh having kids is for sure the gracious
achievement that i have ever had but
it's part of my life so i think it
should really be become part of your
life and not a replacement for your old
life i that's how i believe i do
respect women who feel otherwise of
course but this is how i feel
and um and so yeah zamiyot and textures
are both means by which i try to push
entrepreneurs to do a little bit out of
the box do something a little bit
different
incredible
that it's just really really inspiring
spending most of your time today
with accelerators with tech stars um
why accelerators for you there's a lot
of different ways to support
entrepreneurs and what is it about
accelerators and specifically tech stars
that
that really hits the nail on the head
for you
okay so a true story is that i never
really thought i was gonna do this uh i
was a founder my whole life i had a few
companies i was investing in some
companies i was on the board of some
companies and i never thought that an
accelerator would be my piece of cake
actually and
i never in a million years if you would
told me that i would be running an
accelerator that i would say this
happened
but when i um met techstars for the
first time it was just love at first
sight because i couldn't believe that
there was something so incredible around
the world we're 60 programs and a
portfolio of 200 billion dollars and
smart people from all around the world
who want to help entrepreneurs and
mentors and investors who all want to
help entrepreneurs and invest in the
greatest
uh
i would say top-notch entrepreneurs and
something so big and so global and so um
amazing is so what we call give first
when people just come in and they want
to just help entrepreneurs and i felt
absolutely in love with it which i i
couldn't imagine myself doing anything
else
i love it and so today if you're looking
at the work that you're doing with with
entrepreneurs and
and and the hands-on work what do you
sort of what do you enjoy those there's
a lot of different things that you can
do with with entrepreneurs is it is it
helping them the fundraise is it helping
them with their strategy with their team
coherency which parts of the life cycle
are you mostly well you know i i think
that um every company has their own
secret sauce and i can just help them
and use the the incredible network that
we've created the textures to help them
uh with mentorship and forming their
business but we actually run a
three-month program we also invest in
them
uh so we are
the biggest seed investor in the us
today and we invest in hundreds of
companies um every month
it's incredible because we see the
amazing deal flow from all over the
world we're also seeing great trends and
we're
we're meeting uh founders from all over
the world whether they're in the box or
outside of the box whether they
look exactly like
founders are supposed to look to
investors or whether they're just a
different asset class all together
and uh the first month is all about
mentorship so they meet mentors they
meet between 100 and 150 mentors from
all around the world all of which give
them what we call mental whiplash
and so they hear a lot of opinions and
hearing opinions and being open to
hearing opinions is
you know it's a great help
and then afterwards we work with them on
execution product market fits um
team building and of course fundraising
in the second and third month
we also hold a really great demo day uh
where we uh encourage our entire
community worldwide to come
and it's just incredible because i see
how the startups come in and how they
start to believe and to me it's just the
greatest satisfaction
and so
if you're looking now back to gila and
your hilar the serial entrepreneur the
the change maker in terms of the
ecosystem the the startup mentor and
advisor
and
you know
there's a lot of different i'm very
curious at the end you know why people
do what they do
as you work through these startups what
do you sort of learn about yourself you
know you get to work with all these
different companies in different cycles
and you get exposed to all these
different types of entrepreneurs whoa
what do you learn about yourself
throughout this process wow first of all
that i enjoy more to do this than
anything that i've ever created with my
own hair
right
uh and that's that's really a big deal
because some people just i found out
about myself that i'm a really great
enabler
i love
i mean i i i thrive on those i enjoy
this when my company my first company
uh raised money for the first time or my
first exit it probably was a lot more
meaningful to me that actually
when i did it for the first time
because i felt like i contributed to it
and i had like a really big effect on it
i love people i love seeing very amazing
people from all over the world i love
working with the managing directors
around the world all have been founders
like myself so they're very smart people
around the world
and i'm a great believer in people and i
always knew that about myself but
through working with startups i know
that even more
amazing
i i want to thank you and not just for
these 20 minutes but for your
contribution to our ecosystem to the
amazing amazing work i mean
it's not every day that you know you get
to do something that literally changes a
person's life and i can only imagine the
countless women out of the 8 000 members
that came in and and they found a home
in a community
in a place where you described as very
lonely and you know everybody says that
being an entrepreneur is very lonely and
that's for everybody i can only imagine
you know especially when when you went
in your entrepreneurial journey what
it's like to be the only female in the
room and
i uh appreciate these amazing 20 minutes
you gave me and i appreciate the smart
questions but i also want to say we're
on the right path where we're getting
there i'm optimistic that it's people
like you that didn't
allow people like me to be on stage and
be heard will make a difference also to
so many people who are actually
listening to it and saying hey this
makes sense you know so
completely
i'm excited to continue following the
journey and the amazing things you're
gonna do and thank you very very much
thank you thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
you